the wave of refugees that's flooding
Turkey Greece the Porkins and is heading
north starts here this is Syria right
now the latest trying to flee the
escalating war in some fresh fighting
Islamic state Russian bombers and the
Syrian army are ensuring that these
desperate people are now terrified they
mass near the Turkish border waiting for
smugglers they shelter beneath trees all
huddled in makeshift camps across a
swathe of northern Syria the border is
now closed but they say they have no
choice but to cross
whatever the dangers ahead it's worse at
home this lady is from east of Aleppo
she's ill and hasn't seen her sons in
two years she wants to cross you told us
they destroyed our house we've been
displaced for three years we have no
place to live what can we do
the conditions in these camps are awful
and it's getting worse as winter comes
this year volume of people moving will
doubtless shock the international
community and the roads are
chock-a-block with traffic ferrying
refugees to the north from all over the
country
palms hammered attack yet Aleppo Raqqa
the home of Islamic state these cities
are empty and from d rizal this man says
the russian airstrikes destroyed our
house Islamic state prevented us from
escaping through the fields no idea
where we'll end up
in Turkey itself Syrians now mingle in
towns and cities they plan their next
move towards Europe where whole
communities are being changed here along
the border with Syria by the influx of
huge numbers of Syrian refugees they
don't stay of course many of them move
on what's interesting that the local
government has no idea actually how many
people have come through here it is
hundreds and hundreds of thousands but
they are saying is they are expecting to
have an awful lot more coming through in
the coming days and this is what they're
leaving jihadi group closes in on a
Syrian Army position in their tacky this
is almost hand-to-hand combat
they just feet apart this is an
absolutely chaotic battlefield and it is
huge there's fighting and fighters on
all points of Syria's cumbersome
thousands engaged in deadly battles
different goals different agendas
sometimes just survival firefights in
forest where the enemy can't be seen can
last hours days units and there are
always heavy casualties
[Applause]
[Music]
disti Hadi by a rocket-propelled grenade
survives though he's thinks he's dying
at he's playing he stumbles to find help
from colleagues nearby the battle rages
on from the air Russian planes bomb
targets in non Islamic state areas their
strategy seems to be more about keeping
President Bashar al-assad in power than
destroying is but they are destroying
already battered communities
entire towns are now deserted a
wasteland of bombed-out destruction
nearly every building here has been
razed to the ground no one could survive
this and no one would risk today this is
why they're leaving the international
community all talks over Syria and talks
over refugees as every day and every
night passes more people died and
thousands more flee in search of
sanctuary history of Ramzi sky news on
the syria-turkey border